on la connaît peu pourtant elle est à
l'origine bien malgré elle de l'une des
histoires les plus médiatisés du monde
agricole ces dernières années geneviève
l'abri est une spécialiste des insectes
alors que certains bloquer la
publication de ses résultats d'études
sur les néonicotinoïdes les fameux
pesticides tueurs d'abeilles la grenade
louis robert a dénoncé la situation
c'est entre autres ce qui a mené à son
congédiement en 2019 dans le cadre des
grandes entrevues de notre 50e saison
nous avons rencontré geneviève l'abri
une chercheuse au service des
agriculteurs qui aime profondément la
nature et les insectes
[Musique]
geneviève l'abri gervais vous demandez
pourquoi s'intéresser aux insectes
parce que les insectes sont en aval de
toute musique des systèmes que ça soit
aquatiques que ce soit rs qui sait des
organismes en fait que souvent ignorée
par son tout petit on les voit pas très
bien mais quand on se plonge dans ce
monde sont absolument façon
[Musique]
ils pollinisent les plantes décompose la
matière organique sont une source de
nourriture pour bien des humains
la majorité des insectes nous rendre de
fiers services
ils sont le véritable armée jeu saw
québec on pense qu'on entre 25 et 30
mille espèces d'insectes même souvent on
découvre de nouvelles espèces dans tous
les projets de recherche en général j'ai
découvert de nombreuses espèces au
québec des petites bestioles qu'il faut
se dépêcher d'étudier à l'échelle
mondiale le tiers des espèces d'insectes
serait en voie de disparition
parmi les causes de cette hécatombe
la perte d'habitat les changements
climatiques mais aussi la pollution liés
aux pesticides à vouloir à tout prix
protéger les cultures des ravageurs on a
mal mesuré l'impact sur l'ensemble des
insectes
c'est absolument infinie les services
qui nous arrange
j'aime bien la bri donne l'exemple des
néonicotinoïdes quand j'ai commencé à
travailler au centre de recherche sur
les grains en 2008
on m'a interpellé littéralement
un agronome au ministère qui m'ont
interpellé pour me diriez quoi qu'il se
passe quelque chose en europe
est ce qu'on en a ici est ce que c'est
les grosses questions sans car très
nébuleux mais c'est là qu'on s'est
aperçu en fait c'est à utiliser sur
des superficies vraiment très très très
très grande et qu' il y avait déjà des
problématiques de
de mortalités d'abeilles mise au point à
la fin des années 80 les néonicotinoïdes
ont d'abord été appliquée sur les
feuilles mais c'est surtout depuis leur
utilisation en enrobage de semences
depuis le tournant des années 2000
qu'ils sont montrés du doigt les
néonicotinoïdes ont été dans les
premiers produits à être dits
systémiques systémique ça veut dire
qu'il se lie à un liquide qui est l'eau
et qu'ils rentrent dans la plante pour
pouvoir protéger l'ensemble de la plante
et là c'était une nouvelle façon de
faire ces nouvelles façons d'utiliser un
pesticide je pense que c'est là que eu
des problématiques parce qu'on n'aurait
pas pu penser que ça pouvait se rendre
jusque dans le pollen jusque dans nectar
la recherche a d'ailleurs démontré que
seule une infime partie du pesticide se
fraie un chemin dans le maillet sous le
sceau ya à peine 2 % du produit rendant
la plante et le 98 restants reste autour
de la s'annonce et c'est un des aspects
qui n'a pas été pris en compte du tout
dans tout le processus d'homologation et
qu'est-ce que ça entraîne comme impact
ça entraîne que 98 % du produit reste à
la surface du sol et comme ça se lit
très facilement à l'eau et l'estivé très
facilement et se retrouve dans les cours
d'eau et se retrouve dans l'ensemble de
l'écosystème
dans les régions où l'agriculture est
intensive 100% des cours d'eau sont
contaminés par au moins un héros
nicotine aux ide à des doses qui sont
souvent mortels pour les organismes
aquatiques
cette nouvelle façon d'utiliser les
insecticides devait pourtant être
beaucoup plus sécuritaire contrairement
aux pulvérisations le produit qui enrobe
la semence ne risquait pas d'être
emportée par le vent
l'application était donc plus ciblée
mais la recherche a révélé des dangers
qu'on n'avait pas soupçonné
on a été les premiers à démontrer entre
autres que les flaques d'eau dans les
champs au mois de juin un mois et demi
après le semis même deux mois après le
cemi contenaient des quantités de
nicotine ayed assez importante pour tuer
les abeilles qui viendraient s'y
abreuver les abeilles les ponots
affaires indigènes les autres insectes
aussi donc ça c'est un aspect voit
finalement d'intoxication qui n'avait
jamais été identifié
on n'aurait pas pu penser que les
flaques d'eau dans un champ convenait à
ces pesticides pour lui non plus sympa
[Musique]
à la base ces produits devaient
entraîner une hausse de rendement parce
que l'enrobage des semences protège
notamment contre des insectes du sol
comme les verts fil de fer le problème
c'est que personne n'avait pris le temps
de vérifier si ces ravageurs qui existe
ailleurs au canada et aux états-unis
étaient présents dans nos champs tous
ces produits là en fer ont été utilisés
pour des insectes qu'on a pas mais on ne
le savait pas parce qu'il n'y a pas
beaucoup de recherche qui s'est
effectuée geneviève l'abri et son équipe
ont découvert que dans plus de 95 % des
champs analyser les populations de
ravageurs était si faible qu aucun
traitement n'était justifiée c'était
quelque chose qui a été qu'ils étaient
vraiment étonnant effectivement parce
que ces produits ont toujours été vendus
pour dire faites attention où il ya un
risque d'avoir des ravageurs important
des vars fil de fer de la mouche des
semis des vous allez perdre vos champs
et finalement sur cinq années dans
toutes les régions du québec
ce plusieurs dizaines de réplication en
europe vu aucune différence de route les
néonicotinoïdes devait aussi permettre
de lutter contre le puceron du soya
le hic c'est que ce ravageur émerge une
fois que les insecticides ont perdu
leurs effets si on en est arrivé à
utiliser sur des centaines de milliers
d'hectares des produits qui ne servait à
rien c'est dû à un manque criant de
connaissances selon la chercheuse
avec son équipe elle a donc mené un
projet colossal pendant six ans au
québec 1000 chambres ont été dépistées
pour identifier quels insectes de sol
s'y trouve vraiment cela a permis de
créer un site unique au monde pour
guider les producteurs la majorité des
producteurs no10 eh ben j'ai pas le
choix
la semence arrive enrobé parce que elle
est traitée elle est récoltée aux états
unis aux hôtes avant de le mettre dans
la peau chien en robe la semence pis
nous l'envoie chez nous mais si on va
avoir le choix de la salle ans fo lors
des onze mois j'en veux tu inquiets non
traités mais pour que ce soit le choix
du producteur et non pas que l'on
s'impose
la chercheuse se garde d'ailleurs bien
de blâmer les agriculteurs qui avec ses
produits se procure une certaine paix
d'esprit à faible coût les lionnes
cottineau id le coût d'un produit c'est
à peu près 5 dans l'orne pour par poche
donc 5 $ l'hectare
donc ça a été vraiment utiliser beaucoup
comme assurance tous risques pour les
producteurs qui avait posté à avoir en
tête avec tout au tout les autres
facteurs locke qui doivent gérer
[Musique]
aujourd'hui elle constate que cet usage
préventif malgré l'absence de ravageurs
se poursuit depuis que l'utilisation des
néonicotinoïdes nécessite une
prescription d'un agronome
les agriculteurs se sont tournés vers de
nouveaux produits accessibles en vente
libre en 2021 on s'attend encore à ce
qu'une forte proportion de semences de
maïs et de soya soit toujours en robes
et d'insecticides mais que les produits
est tout simplement changer de nom
présentement les nouveaux traitements de
semences les diamyd se retrouvent dans
des quantités très importantes ont
augmenté de façon exponentielle dans les
cours d'eau tout simplement parce qu'on
a vu ce changement l'eau entre les
lionnes cottineau ide vers la nouvelle
famille de traitement de semences
donc il ya encore un travail à faire
parce qu'on va se retrouver avec une aux
problématiques qui est une contamination
de l'environnement mais avec les
nouveaux traitements de semences qui
sont plus dommageables pour la faune
aquatique encore que les néonicotinoïdes
les scientifiques devront encore une
fois faire la preuve que des produits
autorisés par santé canada ne sont pas
si inoffensif qu'il n'y paraît est-ce
que l'agriculture aujourd'hui peut se
passer de pesticides
on fait souvent le parallèle avec la
médecine est ce qu on pourrait se passer
d'antibiotiques ou de vaccins on le voit
avec la pandémie gérer non à ça parce
qu'un enfer quand on a une grosse
maladie qu'on a un gros ravageur qui
survient c'est si un peu notre nos
derniers outils en fait mais qui nous
permet d'éviter des pertes vraiment
importante
techniquement les pesticides dans la
boîte à outils nos producteurs agricoles
d'un agronome de l'intervenant les
pesticides arrive en dernier lieu
geneviève l'abri mène aujourd'hui des
projets entre autres dans des serres
elle fait partie d'une communauté de
chercheurs en quête de solutions de
rechange aux pesticides selon elle l'une
des clef réside dans la bible
c'est quand on a une certaine quantité
de boisé dans notre environnement c'est
des sites d'hibernation pour nos
prédateurs l'hiver qui ça va être plus
facile pour eux d'aller dans le champ ci
ont juste une mère de maïs bien c'est
sûr que nos prédateurs nos petits gars
parasitoïdes seront pas capables de
faire le chemin jusque dans les lieux du
chat donc d'améliorer et d'augmenter
notre diversité dans notre environnement
bonne nécessairement nous permettre
d'arriver à un certain équilibre dans
notre écosystème danone agro écosystèmes
et si on veut réduire notre usage des
pesticides
elle insiste il faut dépister vérifier
si on a vraiment un problème
au lieu de traiter à l'aveuglé et elle
rappelle l'importance des rotations de
cultures dans la lutte contre les
insectes nuisibles
geneviève vous vouliez conviennent dans
un champ de sarrasin aujourd'hui
pourquoi le sarrasin c'est une culture
qui est un peu oubliée au québec mais
quitter dans les rotations quand même de
nos grands pères qui était vraiment
utilisé dans les rotations parce que tu
n'as blé noir c'est un lieu de
biodiversité mais incroyable on voit le
site emploie présentement mais si on se
promène on veut trouver une dizaine
d'espèces différentes de coccinelles
plein de prédateurs de toutes sortes
d'insectes plein de petites guêpes
parasitoïdes mais ça peut être un
réservoir d'ennemis naturels pour les
cultures qui sont autour
nos ancêtres savaient déjà que le
sarrasin barre la voie à de nombreuses
maladies
mais une chercheuse d'agriculture canada
est arrivé récemment à des résultats
renversant cette plante élimine aussi
certains ravageurs
c'est 100 % de mortalité les vins fil de
fer quand il s'alimente sur le sarrasin
que pendant une certaine période de
temps
les néonicotinoïdes et même les nouveaux
traitements de semences ne tue pas les
verts fil de fer ça ne lui pose ça fait
juste les rendent malade et finalement
la population et ce taux reste toujours
la main blanche
donc c'est pas une solution
nécessairement à long terme des
traitements de semences à 5,7 parce que
finalement on réduit pas notre
populations de ravageurs
[Musique]
on peut pas changer tout jour au
lendemain mais par quoi on devrait
commencer
qu'est-ce qui est le plus urgent je
dirais qu'on a besoin de support souvent
les projets de recherche on a des bons
résultats mais ça reste sur une tablette
et c'est pas ça sans bobo aux
producteurs agricoles c'est là dessus
qu'il faut travailler pour qu'ils
puissent être en mesure d'avoir vraiment
le rendement optimal sur leur ferme mais
aussi un environnement diversifié puis
qui protège bien la population leur part
tous deux alternatives
[Musique]
malgré les preuves qui s'accumulent 1
contre eux les néonicotinoïdes ont
bénéficié d'une autorisation temporaire
de santé canada pendant plus de dix ans
une réévaluation de certaines de ses
molécules est actuellement en cours
elle a débuté en 2016 et des décisions
sont attendues au printemps 2021